joining me now is Dan bond Gino former
Secret Service agent and author of the
new book spy gate and also joining me is
Rochelle Richey former press secretary
for the House Democrats Rochelle let's
start with you what will the Democratic
response be if something horrific
happens because of the anger and the
frenzy both Congress women senators and
others are either tacitly encouraging or
actually encouraging with their words
well Laura you know you mentioned that
someone might be killed as a result of
what we're hearing coming from the left
but I want to say that someone already
has been killed as a result of what's
coming from the right and that's how
their hair and really the hypocrisy that
we're seeing coming from Republicans
right now is killing objective thinking
the inability of the GOP to think
objectively and to hold themselves to
the same Accord as they hold everyone
else is literally like a plague that is
spreading throughout our politics if we
think that people banging on the doors
of the Supreme Court aimlessly you know
it was kind of ridiculous I will admit
but if we think those people are a mob
then we should also think that the
people that do matter
Rochelle Jim is that was that what you
actually consider to be civil protests
or what we saw with antifa in Portland
harassing an elderly American holding up
a goat no claim I don't claim auntie feh
and like I just said a second ago I
thought banging on the doors of the
Supreme Court aimlessly was a little bit
ridiculous but also keep in mind that
congressman cleaver was actually spat on
during the Tea Party movement from
people who were angry about Obamacare so
that is what was encouraging that who
was encouraging that no one was
encouraging that no Republicans said get
in their faces go out and harass them go
to restaurants dan but you know you had
you in on this we wanted our Jake people
to do that that never had there were
there were but it hurt yes there were no
there were we'll get to it yeah I just
want to note that what Rochelle just did
is really gross and I want to call her
out for that immediately what happened
to miss hire in in Charlotte I didn't
interrupt you I'd appreciate if you'd
let me
be it's the right thing to do we're
trying to be civil correct okay thank
you now we are what you did was
grotesque what you did was quite gross
the Republicans Donald Trump and
conservatives have absolutely nothing to
do with a deranged murdering maniac who
runs a woman over in Charlottesville
that is gross president Trump denounced
that immediately and you bringing that
up in the context people on both show
detail why don't you just take over the
debate go ahead because you're the civil
one go ahead well thank you I'm allowed
to speak now okay I appreciate your
permission there let him say something
you can respond Rochelle that'll be fine
okay the point is what you're doing is
you didn't answer the question
immediately you've distracted everybody
by going to Charlottesville which the
Republicans denounced and then you had a
fabricated another one that cleaver was
spit on he was not spit on her making
that up those stories about what
happened during the Obamacare debate are
completely fabricated these are nonsense
events you were asked a simple question
about if you should denounce violence on
the left and you made it about something
else other than answered a question
which frequently liberals do Rochelle
well I'm just gonna respond by saying
this first of all that story is
completely true you know I would
encourage going back into cleaver in the
state well let's try to keep it because
we have limited time let's come in keep
it focus to what's happening right now
because I think we all do care about
what kids take away from this whether
it's a kids in an immigration video
saying eff the president putting up
their middle finger or whether it's
people going up to individuals with
their children or their family their
wives or husbands in a restaurant and
screaming them out of a restaurant it is
incumbent upon both Republicans and
Democrats agreed to stand up and say no
you will not do this we don't we don't
countenance this and when Eric Holder is
out there saying we'll kick them I mean
Michelle Obama actually said when they
go low we'll go high mm-hmm and
apparently Eric Holder's is like no
we're not gonna go we're gonna kick them
and maybe even worse who knows well you
can't you can't be for that Rochelle
oh absolutely not I definitely don't
think that you should assault anyone but
I also think that we have to remember
and if people go back and look at what
Eric Holder said he followed that
statement up was saying I don't think
that we should do anything
egle or inappropriate so I'm taking this
kick them is kicked them out of the
house and kicked them out of the Senate
come November but is that how things are
shared Dan on social media going back to
the way young people consume media what
are they going to consume dan you know
Laura I I just can't understand why the
left just can't simply admit their
people make mistakes and say really dumb
things
now Eric Holder was talking about
kicking them out of the house and that
is not what he said I mean something
really quickly this is from Rand Paul's
wife Kelly after of course a lot of this
chaos out there said this back on
October 8th just a couple days ago let's
watch are so many frankly unhinged
people and unstable people out there and
when they hear someone on their side
telling them get up in their face they
take that literally because of the
violence that Rand has experienced in
the last year it does scare me that
there was going to be somebody that is
really unstable that takes that message
a step further we've updated all of our
security systems at home we I sleep with
a loaded gun by my bed Dan yeah I mean
he was attacked he had broken ribs he
apparently he's coming down with
frequent cases of pneumonia now I mean
these are real cases these aren't
fabricated cases like the Sarah Palin
pact with the bullseye pictogram to
raise money these are real cases of
leftist violence I just wish the left
would step up and say hey this is all
wrong we condemn it Maxine Waters Eric
Holder Hillary Clinton tone it down it's
not right both of you thank you so much
I have you both back fantastic segment
and the